ouais c'est vrai qu'il ya à peu près
qu'un dix quinze ans ça m'a fait sourire
passant il c'est vrai que bon bon on a
le même nom c'est une chose mais on a
surtout le même prénom et c'est ça le
progrès acquis fauvergue et moi en fait
j'ai déposé ma marque depuis puisque
j'ai ouvert mon premier salon en 95 donc
c'est une marque déposée et derrière ça
j'ai un groupe des franchises et c'est
vrai que ça a commencé où c'est écrit en
gros est récusée mois au service normal
bah oui c'est heureusement qu'à part un
fabio salsa qui se présentait
donc et du coup c'est vrai que ça a
commencé au début ça faisait un petit
peu sourire parce que c'est vrai que les
gens bon ben c'est surtout sur internet
et les réseaux sociaux qui a été le plus
compliqué au début et puis bon après
c'est devenu de plus en plus et puis bon
là aujourd'hui
je suis content d'être là parce qu'en
fait c'est vrai d'arriver à casser des
vitrines de salon alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé cela ouais en fait il s'est
passé il ya à peu près de trois semaines
d'abord dans ce salon la la maison mère
bien sûr
le 1er janvier on m'a pris quatre
vitrines casser la vitrine pays s'est
rien passé plus qu'on a bloqué à un peu
et puis là il ya quinze jours j'ai un
salon un autre sur nice dans le vieux
nice et là en revanche on a vraiment
cassé toute la vitrine ils sont rentrés
ils ont pris deux trois petites choses
entre
ces gens pensent vraiment que eric
zemmour
c'est certain que c'est incroyable alors
c'est vrai que ça vous fait rire il
paraît qu'on a les mêmes tags et une
croix gammée jeu suivant votre instinct
de beaux établissements en 2015 moins
que ça donc quand il s'est présenté à la
présidentielle ce que vous vous êtes dit
ça va être compliqué oui c'est je me
suis dit ça parce qu'en fait bon moi
j'ai plus je suis pas tout le temps dans
les salons m'assurerai que bon j'exerce
depuis plus de 30 ans et puis gens que
je suis coiffeur ambassadeur pour
l'oréal professionnel je fais partie de
l'équipe de création de la haute
coiffure française qui est vraiment une
équipe artistique dans le monde de la
coiffure et puis depuis pas très
longtemps j'ai je suis directeur
artistique du groupe pascal costes qui
existe et qu'il ya 350 ans en france
donc la grecque attendant c'est
dérangeant est bien implantée dans la
coque voilà donc envie de faire quelque
chose pour le monsieur
aussi moi j'ai pas d'outil ouais mais je
pense qu'elle a tout ce qu'il faut l'y
paris est ce qu'il ya des employés qui
sont pris à partie
non c'est les employés en fait ça les
dérange un peu par exemple aujourd'hui
on a eu on a eu pas mal d'interviews
parce que lui en fait il a tweeté source
alors il a tweeté rigolard il a mis
certains cas mignacca tout un soutien ou
leur rejet contre la racaille c'est ça
qui a tout déclenché et c'est vrai que
la balle était là aujourd'hui
dans les salons on a eu des clients des
gens qui a appelé pour dire j'ai un
rendez vous madame le pen où je
m'appelle monsieur mélenchon et des
choses comme ça donc ça c'est vraiment
perdre loup à la loi vatican alors
j'espère que tout le monde va comprendre
qu'en fait je suis eric zemmour mais je
suis coiffeur voilà j'aime aucun rapport
avec lui et que et que voilà aujourd'hui
comptez pas vous présenter non pas du
tout en rêvant de la mode je rends les
femmes belles je vends du rêve ce accord
et je continue dans cette danse est
d'accord et quoi voilà donc voilà au
mois voilà c'est oui j'ai dit est ce que
vous avez constaté une baisse depuis ça
sur notre chiffre d'affaires enfin c'est
compliqué par pourvoi non pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait on a quand même nos
clientes habituelles qui aujourd'hui on
était présent sur les réseaux sociaux
donc les réseaux sociaux sont pour moi
un outil de travail donc c'est vrai que
je reçois quand même beaucoup de il ya
des gens qui parlent carrément sur les
réseaux sociaux sur mon compte pensant
lui parler à lui pour que on n'a pas la
même tête au débat et c'est vrai le 2 2
2 en même temps lui donc je dis à tout
le monde c'est eric zemmour avec un tir
est bon pour tous les gens qui va lui
parler c'est eric zemmour avec un tir et
moi c'est eric zemmour tout simple
hockey et puis on a tous les deux notre
tête vous serez d'en face à bah
oui guillaume eric zemmour avait quand
même des années qu'il est médiatisé
qu'il est connu pour ses idées qui
divisent est ce que vous aviez déjà eu
des problèmes avec ça ou c'est vraiment
sa candidature mais il a été connu avant
lui oui c'est vrai c'est gentil c'est un
peu moi j'ai fait aussi un peu de télé
réalité à l'époque j'ai fait les
premières émissaires avec panique chez
le coiffeur bien sûr les lions s'étaient
rencontrés à 12 ans exactement j'étais
enfant j'étais en panique déchets et
donc voila et donc c'est vrai que j'ai
un peu j'ai un peu fréquenté le milieu
de la télé réalité c'était super sympa
ça m'a aidée aussi mais bon après sans
prétention c'est vrai que j'ai été
j'étais là avant lui en même temps alors